- What's up y'all, I'm
hanging out with Vin Diesel!
(audience cheering)
Well, you're a kid of
1980s, New York city, so,
let's end this with a quick
game of 80s this or that.
Are you ready?
- Yeah.
- Okay, Hot Pockets or Pop Secret?
- Oh my God.
- I mean, there's really
just one option, but fine.
- Okay, um.
Did I do, I definitely
didn't do Hot Pockets.
- You didn't?
Is that a southern thing?
- Yes, I've never met a person
in my life that ate Hot Pockets.
- Oh, you have now, brother.
- Woo! (clapping)
She's like, "Go ahead, girl!"
- I grew up on cheap, poor people food.
So yeah, I definitely had.
- No, we didn't do Hot Pockets.
- We ate it microwaveable.
Well, my mom was a single mom.
It was all microwave.
What can we throw in the microwave?
- [Vin] Oh, okay.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- My mom didn't have a microwave.
- [Kelly] Oh?
- It was one of those kind of homeopathic.
- Oh God, see that's so good.
- We had wheat bread.
We weren't, then it was
whole grain bread, it was.
- [Kelly] Oh gosh, okay, that was,
we grew up in different houses.
- No soda allowed.
- Oh, yeah, no, I lived on Dr. Pepper.
There's a reason how I ended up here.
So, (laughing) so, Pac-Man or Gallagher?
- I was a Pac-Man, but
I will tell you this,
now I gotta bring it up
and I should confess.
(Kelly laughing)
There was a bowling alley and
there was a Pac-Man machine.
And my, I had a friend that
taught me how to tape a quarter,
- [Kelly] What?
- To a fishing line.
- And you could pull it back out.
- And we used to go and so we ended
up playing Pac-Man all
night, cause we were able to.
- Here's the thing, I don't
think that's stealing.
I think that's clever.
- That's clever.
- I think that's, you know
what, that's being resourceful.
- It's being resourceful,
we took one quarter
and played a 100 games.
- Yeah, hey, you cheated
the system fairly I think.
- [Vin] Yes.
- Cheated the system
fairly, do you like that?
- I like that.
- Okay, so parachute pants
or acid washed jeans?
I'm Southern, so I have to go acid washed.
- You have to go and acid washed.
I guess I have to go acid washed
because I wasn't doing parachute.
- Okay, flock of seagulls hair or mullet?
I mean, you know.
- (chuckles) Which 80s is this?
- Wait, flock of seagulls?
- I'm joking, I'm joking.
- You didn't get to do flock of seagulls?
- I was doing Run DMC.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay, okay.
- I told you, brake dancing.
- Okay, okay, or not mullet either?
Neither.
- No, not mullet either.
- Mullet is definitely where I'm from.
- Gotcha, gotcha.
- Okay, Matchbox Cars or Micro Machines?
- Matchbox.
- Yeah, me too, yeah, all the way.
This is a hard one,
Michael Jackson or Prince?
That's hard, this is a
big debate for people.
- It's too big a debate because both
of them represent so much to try to,
it would be a blasphemy to.
- Not me, I go Prince.
I like both, but Prince
I liked a bit more.
Don't beat me.
- No, I'm not gonna beat you, (laughinG)
I just wanna say, wait a minute.
Okay, let's, let's think about this.
- Let's think about this.
- Is there a Prince
without a Michael Jackson?
Prince does something incredible.
He's a true crossover artist.
He's hitting all demographics.
He's hitting everybody,
because he's coming
out with something reminiscent
of a Jimmy Hendrix.
He playing, he's doing what
Jimmy Hendrix was doing
in the sixties.
But what Michael Jackson did
almost pre hip hop is profound.
What he does for black music
in the beginning is mind boggling.
- Oh, I think it's great.
Okay, here's a really hard one.
I'm throwing it in, that's right.
Whitney or Mariah?
What?
That's hard.
Whitney or Mariah?
Here's the thing, I'm
actually pleading the fifth
on that one. (laughing)
- Oh, come on, you gotta do
it, what would you guys pick?
Mariah or Whitney?
- You don't want to do it, do you?
- Wait, wait.
Oh, we got a bunch of Whitneys.
- [Vin] That's a Whitneys.
- That's a Whitneys.
- Go, go.
- Okay, okay.
- But Mariah is amazing with
her amazing contributions.
- Vin, I will say nobody
gives her the credit
as like all those hits
were written from her hand.
That is incredible.
- Yeah.
- Think of the number one she has had
in her career, because there's a billion.
Even if they're not number
ones, they're just great songs.
Like it's an amazing thing, she was-
- Such a contribution to music.
- As writer, yeah.
Anyway, well thank you for dropping by.
I liked playing games
and talk about music.
- Yes, oh, we could talk
about music forever.
- I will talk for hours.
I love your upbringing, I
want to talk more about that.
I want your family from your childhood.
- I want you to hear all my music.
- I know.
Well, Vin Diesel, everybody.
(audience cheering)
F9 is in theaters this
Friday, everybody go see it.